sie alle wollen auf und davon
christine schönbächler und ihr mann
hermann sie ziehen mit ihren kindern
welche und natascha nach kanada anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollen sich in
italien eine existenz aufbauen mit dabei
ist gino der trüffel und aniko und
orlando stamm geben ihrer jungen liebe
ein neues zuhause auf bali bauen sie
eine ferienanlage jennifer wettstein der
mann ali und söhnchen sven versprechen
sich in peru eine bessere zukunft in
lima sollen ihre träume wahr werden
[Musik]
mein bruder
ob ich war vor einer woche in auf und
davon
hermann schönbächler kehrte für die
schweizermeisterschaft im holzfällen
inhalte heimat zurück und holte sich den
titel
während seine frau christine allein mit
den kindern im kanadischen rost blieb
orlando stammen sahen wir in ungewohnter
kleidung zusammen mit seiner partnerin
anni kuhn durfte er in bali endlich die
ferien anlage einweihen tierischen
zuwachs gab es in italien blut wegmann
und anja kinski haben jetzt auf ihrem
kleinen hof hühner getrennte wege gingen
für eine weile ali wettstein und seine
frau jenny während er in der schweiz auf
dem bau krampfte hielt sie in lima das
restaurant im betrieb und kümmerte sich
um klein sven
[Musik]
während die schönbächlers noch in ihrer
kleinen wohnung in biel zu hause geht es
heute vielleicht fischstäbchen aus der
gefriertruhe
[Gelächter]
doch diese zeiten sind endgültig vorbei
zu ihrem neuen leben in kanada gehört
dass sie fast immer wenn sie dazu lust
haben frischen fisch haben können
[Musik]
hier am pelham lake im norden kanadas
sollen die kinder natascha und regie im
einklang mit der natur aufwachsen
sie sollen die rauen aber auch die
zahlten seiten des lebens kennenlernen
hab deine facebook freunde gestorben war
[Gelächter]
hermann will den haken der sich im
wasser verfangen hat nicht kampflos
aufgeben
nichts zu machen
die schönbächlers müssen einsehen dass
die natur hier oben nicht nur gibt
sondern hin und wieder auch nimmt in
bali gehen tradition und moderne hand in
hand einheimische frauen tragen die
schweren lasten auf dem kopf während
sich die schweizer hotelbesitzer ganz
dem technischen fortschritt widmen
endlich kann orlando stamm in seiner
rezeption im internet surfen
anni kuhn hofft derweil die neue
waschmaschine in betrieb nehmen zu
können
er trägt als erzählerin durch
aber im moment kommt zwar sei in
stuttgart seit bald einem jahr leben
anni und orlando auf der götter insel
bali die vielen kleinen hindernisse im
alltag konnten ihrer liebe bisher nichts
anhaben und mit ihrem logo manager
kuhmann haben sie einen eifrigen und
willigen helfer funktioniert nicht nein
dieses teiles gebrochen
dieses neue teil schaut zwar besser aus
ist aber nichts wert das ist kaputt
immer diese miese qualität heraus
problem ist dass die sanitären anlagen
dauer immer das problem dieser herr k
und jetzt plötzlich wenn sie
installieren und dienste anbieten
bz wie hier beim triumph situation war
das ganze haus
wir müssen die waschmaschine brauchen
kann
die haben so viele dreckige tücher und
kleider
[Musik]
während sich anja kinski und claude
wegmann vor vier jahren nicht begegnet
dann legen diese 35 hektaren land immer
noch in einem dornröschenschlaf
so aber lässt sich claude heute im
eigenen wahl stück in die geheimnisse
der trüffelsuche einweihen
claudio dieser 2 dieser kleine strauch
ist hier oben abgebrochen aber nicht
etwa durch den schnee oder durch tiere
sondern jemand hat ihn ganz bewusst hier
oben geknickt das ist das zeichen eines
trüffelsuche die hat ihn absichtlich so
hingebogen als wollte er sagen hier
geht's lang paulo hat zwei erfahrene
trüffel hunde dabei foto und lagerung
von ihnen soll juno lernen wie man die
kostbaren knollen findet denn claude
oder claudio wie er hier inzwischen
gerufen wird will im agriturismo seinen
gästen trüffel gerichte anbieten können
welch ein duft wo bist du kleiner
trüffel und da noch ein kleines drücken
sie mal
dieser duft wirft die erde weg werden in
den kleinen gut gemacht
gino der labrador romagnolo ist zwar
eben erst einjährig geworden und sucht
heute erstmals im wald nach treffen
doch eines weiß er schon was du gefunden
hast musst du lautstark verteidigen
mit großem stolz bringt claude den
kleinen hund nach hause
[Musik]
natürlich ein bisschen flunkern wird man
wohl noch dürfen
[Musik]
sie spiegeln gewerke mit alkohol kommen
immerhin
[Musik]
wäre das leben von ali wettstein in den
letzten jahren immer nur nach plan
gelaufen dann würde er heute kaum seinen
sohn sven in lima zur krippe bringen
[Musik]
doch ali ist ein junger mann mit vielen
ideen und noch mehr tatendrang
seit einem jahr wohnen die wettstein in
der heimat von jenni
sie führt hier ihr unternehmen rewe
masses und war im letzten jahr auch
verantwortlich für die neulancierung der
elterlichen pasta fabrik
doch weil jenny heute ein bisschen
kränkelt fährt ali an ihrer stelle in
die fabrik 500 kilogramm pasta werden
täglich im familienbetrieb hergestellt
viel mehr als noch vor wenigen monaten
der gelernte haustechnik installateur
aus bern führt uns durch sein neues
teigwaren sortiment
dann würde das ist nicht nur für die mit
dem spiel
gegen den vorwurf habe sich in ein
gemachtes nest gesetzt nimmt er gelassen
[Musik]
um insider sagte er versucht den
widerstand war
das wort cool ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wenn jeder so leben immer gesagt
dass ich hier überhaupt
sie stiegen die gewinne mit der fall
buwog kommen
[Musik]
bereits werden die tage wieder kürzer in
rasur im geheimnisvollen wald rund ums
haus der familie schönbächler leben
nicht nur viele tiere im wald wachsen
auch schmackhafte pilze die in guten
jahren viel geld einbringen
das süßeste geheimnis verbirgt sich
jedoch unter dem herzen von christine
und nicht im waldboden
sie ist im sechsten monat schwanger bin
froh dass ich im winter wenn hier ab und
zu schneestürme thoben soll das kind zur
welt kommen aber auch das würde
christine sagen gehört einfach dazu dass
ich so dass ich sowieso
ja ja
das
dafür bekommt die chance dass
[Musik]
frühmorgens im palmgarten amet orlando
stamm und anni kuhn werden in wenigen
tagen ihre ferien anlage eröffnen heute
morgen besuchen sie mit ihrer
neuenkirchen kaputt den markt
[Musik]
die frau wenn sie etwas sagen
vier jahre nachdem sie ein paar wurden
haben sich anni kuhn und orlando stammen
an den alltag bales gewöhnt und finden
sich in ihrer neuen heimat von tag zu
tag besser zurecht
[Musik]
wer ferien auf dem bauernhof in italien
anbieten will braucht früher oder später
ein entsprechendes fahrzeug claudio und
anja kaufen sich heute einen traktor
genauer ihr nachbar gian mario
verkauften beiden einen 30 jährigen fiat
brauchen schlepper
die lage
mio
[Applaus]
schiller
geboren
[Applaus]
das blau
es gefällt und was sagen ihm gefällt das
land man auch schnell und anschließend
versuchen sie es ebenfalls nein nein ich
habe keine ahnung wie das geht
da kommt mein herrchen
[Applaus]
und jetzt
gleichwohl hans auch im sport zu sehen
aber es ist die sorge was und wann
welcher stufe findling oberhof ist
natürlich viel zu hoch gewählt wird und
ganz klar klären und so
da hab ich habe gern maschine aber das
ist halt so
die gewinnlose
[Musik]
in peru können sich thalys wenn und
jenny zusammen mit dennis mutter sarah
ein paar tage der erholung im dschungel
erstmals seit ali aus der schweiz
zurückgekehrt ist haben die drei ferien
für jenny ist es eine rückkehr zu ihren
wurzeln
ihre vorfahren stammten aus einem dorf
unweit von hier irgendwie passt das
sie haben eine sie haben eine gute
verbindung mit gott weil sie ganz neu
von dort ziehen weil ich ins paradies
[Musik]
die letzten monate waren für die junge
familie eine echte prüfung ali arbeitete
in der schweiz
jenny war oft auf sich allein gestellt
umso mehr genießen sie jetzt die tage in
dieser traumhaften umgebung
[Musik]
sommer
oh mein gott schaut 50 werde ich bin
wirklich ich kann nicht schauen werde
gar nicht schauen bevor sein das weiß
gegangen ist wie bei einem winken nun am
streiten dann hat man keine zeit für uns
gerade überhaupt keine und dass wir
wirklich so dass wenn das alles gefühlt
das wenig auf die finalisten
im moment ist alles gut wir haben ein
bisschen gebraucht auch diese drei
monaten zu vermissen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in bali werden in den nächsten wochen
die ersten gäste erwartet
höchste zeit für anni und orlando
mitarbeiterinnen für ihre kleine
wellness oase zu finden
zwei junge frauen möchten sich für die
massage empfehlen für die einheimischen
bietet das ferienressort des schweizer
paares willkommene arbeitsplätze
die kandidatinnen geben sich große mühe
mehr
ich glaube dass sie hatten wegen der
aschewolke
war die massage gut magst du es magst du
noch mehr ja wunderbar noch nicht nur
das bundesgericht starb mit echten
im nordwesten kanadas in den wäldern von
ross mit braut sich am abend des 10
oktober 2010 etwas zusammen
[Musik]
bald schon hört hermann schönbächler
rund ums haus bäume krach
[Musik]
zugleich verwies
früh am nächsten morgen herr man
verschafft sich einen überblick in der
unmittelbaren umgebung des hauses
der zufahrtsweg ist von umgefallenen
tannen versperrt strom und
telefonleitungen sind unterbrochen haben
mit den hemden oder blusen oder roulette
von denen knacken dabei ihm das ist
haus nummer größer oder s-bahn und
natürlich fragt sich nicht nur hermann
was passieren würde wenn ein sturm
ausgerechnet dann wütet wenn christina
ins spital muss um ihr kind zur welt zu
bringen
wahrscheinlich die straße brachte sind
stoppt offen ich muss die bühne noch
dauerhaft vertrauen dass das man da
hilft unterstützt hervorgezaubert
reisenden auch gerade in italien ist es
kalt geworden dass rund um das anwesen
israel ist es allen sauwohl
frühstück noch aus geboren im ort an der
elbe noch und im februar dann sollte der
nachwuchs bei mindestens zwei mal im
jahr und der nachwuchs wird dann wieder
buch versucht oder geschlachtet verkauft
marthe und mathilde die neuen säule
gehören zur rasse der chinese zwei
scheine vier ziegen vier hühner und ein
trüffel und der bahnhof nimmt langsam
formen an
doch noch immer verursacht das
agriturismo nur kosten und keine
einnahmen
relativ anspruchslos in der haltung also
wenn sie dann mal wenn frühjahr kommt
dann werden sie auch die ganze zeit
draußen sein dann können die sich
hauptsächlich von dem gras ernähren dann
fressen die ja ist blätter und macht
spaß
erst wollten wir ja schafskäse machen
aber irgendwie kam das dann eigentlich
dass wir dann gesagt haben wir probieren
jetzt erstmal mit siegen ziehen sie dem
problem ist ja dass eigentlich alle
ringsum hand schaut euch einfach die
kategorien also spricht auf orientiert
davon wenn wir nicht an oder über
schwaben mit einer neuen pecorino so ein
begeisterter und geist irgendwo im
vergleich zu der show
intelligente und aktiver und und macht
so viel spaß eines hauses schaffen
[Musik]
im wald von ross gut versteht an diesem
morgen hermann schönbächler der seit
mehr als 20 jahren förster ist die welt
nicht mehr
das ist hier das ist großer einzige
jetzt weiß ich warum das das letzte
große bastion
was nach dieser verwüstung von fast
biblischem ausmaß an arbeit auf hermann
schönbächler waltet überwältigt den
bodenständigen berner
[Musik]
die unheimlich traurig der motor der
waldpark im grunde aus meisterstück war
eine nachhaltige forstwirtschaft
demonstrieren und vorführen und
botanisch der caritas nun der
betrunkenen dem werkstück bedroht
da hat die keinen grund noch die
nächsten 20 jahre hektar misst
vorstellen
[Musik]
in lima herrscht eine ganz andere
stimmungslage ali beckstein ist stolz
auf das resultat seiner bemühungen das
restaurant floriert
[Musik]
wenn wir ein operatives nicht zwei jahre
zurück durch das fest doch auch hier
eigentlich immer damals ich mir im laufe
der umsatz sie wählen wir den starts im
moment die schweiz restaurant samt ist
und ich stehe voll und das macht erfreut
ein knappes jahr nachdem er bären mit
seiner familie verlassen hat ist seine
bilanz positiv
ali und der nie haben sich in lima gut
eingelebt und freunde gefunden
beide haben sie einen langen weg hinter
sich
doch nun sind sie an dem ort an dem sie
glücklich werden wollen
der große augenblick auf den aniko und
orlando stamm ein jahr lang gewartet
haben
die ersten gäste sind da
was mit ein paar skizzen begonnen hat
ist jetzt vollendet ein kleines paradies
und das sogar wirkung
es ist so schön schöner sagt sie das
denn jetzt planer und sehe dass ein
start unmöglich hannover planungen
realisieren
wir sind zu stolz ist er da wirklich
einen blick cappuccino aber mehr und so
viel und so viel investiert und ich
glaube auch eine reise kraftstoff
verkehren
also ich glaube den hammers gemacht da
hat sich lohnt also ich jeden tag auch
weil man sich und trägt oder sagt als
ich jede verpflichtung und verschweißt
raum stehen an diesem tag 24 stunden
zusammen und es ist
[Musik]
bis
vor einem jahr begann für anja und
claude das abenteuer italien in ein paar
monaten wollen sie hier gäste
beherbergen in ihrem agriturismo dressur
l darauf stoßen anja und claude heute an
und auch das was sie als bar erreicht
haben
nein danke
so ist hier keine spur dieser auch
berlin hat räume hand wo irgendwo in
tagen arbeitete jeder macht sein job und
und pichai
das ist sicher langweilig oder
schwieriger für ihre beziehung ausland
besorgt bisher zusammen besuchten oder
verwirklichen also ich da gesagt für gm
braucht das dass sie belastet natürlich
birgt die dieses projekt auch
konfliktpotenzial weil man einfach
unheimlich viel entscheiden muss wie
macht man weiter kauft man ein schwein
kauft man gleich 50 schweine da gibt es
viele diskussionen ja aber letztendlich
haben wir es so immer ganz gut
gemeistert und jetzt muss man einfach
schauen wie es weitergeht
ja also vorher millionen kunden
schwebend verdanken dass er geht
anbieter wie man so angetan dass
baubewilligung war dann alles besitzt er
eine weniger wird aus dankt aber waren
viele gemacht und fehler erlaubt also
folgerichtig aber nicht da war einfach
auch sehr viel administrative es zu
erledigen
und man merkt natürlich bei so einem
vorhaben das die dinge doch länger
brauchen als mal anfangs dachte und
immer wieder neue kleinere
schwierigkeiten auftreten
ja aber wir haben es eigentlich relativ
soll ich sagen gut gemeistert gut
gemeistert ja weit kommt
[Musik]
sambora in der millionenstadt lima immer
am montag canali das restaurant bereits
um 18 uhr dichtmachen und früher nach
hause kommen auch nelly das
dienstmädchen ist um diese zeit noch da
die junge familie ist glücklich im neuen
zuhause und dafür gibt es einen guten
grund
[Musik]
jenny ist im zweiten monat schwanger
zwar müsste aber man kann es noch nicht
sagt dritter vierter monat fährt vom
vierter gern
ja und wir haben ein bisschen probleme
gehabt habe zu viel stress gehabt so
muss jetzt ein bisschen zu hause bleiben
weil ich habe schon sowie welchen gehabt
bis 10
tatsächlich schon früher so frau niveau
extrem eifersüchtig
daher sind wir sind ja es hat des
kreises bruder schwester lisa es darum
durch eine schwarze katze davon vom buch
vorgestellt erste liste hin und her
musste ging
[Musik]
in der januar 2011 in kanada schwelgt
die familie schönbächler im glück das
ist das nicht unbedingt wählen und am
samstag den 22 januar 2011 kam das
mädchen zur welt
die geburt verlief problemlos die eltern
waren mit dem auto ins spital nach paris
gefahren und nach zwei stunden war
alexandra estelle jd da gesund und
munter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
raus aus dem euro familie wert der
familie struktur der kämmerer ist ganz
ganz schön ist das christlich schlossen
zumindest mit einer barke mit einer ganz
gut
[Musik]
das papier stieg die mit mittagsschlaf
im bett dass papa hermann selber
gezimmert hat alexandra steht für das
glück das die familie schönbächler in
kanada erleben darf mitten in der
kanadischen wildnis
an den sturm der vor ein paar monaten
einen großen teil der wald zerstört hat
mag der holzfäller in diesen tagen gar
nicht denken
finanziell hatte für das problem ist
einfach dass medizin die arbeit und der
profit wollen
neustadt 20 jahre uhrmacher dennoch
strom der ist oder innerhalb jahr machen
bevor dass das holz an bord eines kaputt
ist doch im moment steht ihm der sinn
nicht nach sorgen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz überrascht von der 27 fahrer und
ein remis dazu einmal angefahren werden
das ist die macht das so gut das ziel
natürlich mit stolz da sagte natascha
der erste halbjahr vor ihrem leben so
viel verantwortungsbewusstsein
wahrscheinlich ist es die sehnsucht die
den menschen immer wieder einen
neuanfang wagen lässt die sehnsucht nach
einem leben in freiheit und ohne zwang
anja und claude wagten diesen schritt
und werden weiterhin fleißig an ihrem
agriturismo bauen ali jenny und sven
blicken in lima voller freude in die
zukunft die ihnen ein weiteres bübchen
bringen wird
anni und orlando fanden auf der götter
insel bali für ihre liebe ein neues
zuhause und die kleine alexandra hat in
kanada das glück der familie
schönbächler perfekt gemacht
[Musik]